hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu gut
ich habe mir mal wieder eure kommentare
durchgelesen und da wurde mir sehr
aufgeschrieben dass es hier irgendwo ein
coffee steyn studio gibt wo man was
machen kann in diesem copy steyn studio
also coffee stellen sind die entwickler
von gott simulator da soll es wohl
möglich sein flirt ingo zu spielen
ich denke allerdings nicht dass das
studio hier ist liebe ziege ich habe mir
jetzt einfach mal einen kleinen
touristenführer geholt er mehr zeit wo
das ist das ist der fritz zeigt mir dass
jetzt da vorne slow gravity testing
facility da können wir theoretisch mal
eben kurz schauen auch kummer fritz dame
jedoch sogar ein freund hier
jeder hasst mich hier wohl second slater
das ist nicht wahr dass spiele ich mal
wieder gott simulierter freunde mich mit
den leuten haben und dann fritz was man
was bleibt dann gefälligst und fritz
viel stellt sich jetzt ins tor und
versuchten einen schuss zu halten
etwa
der escalade quickly hier vorne haben
wir komme ich darüber
ich bin drehen und ihr [ __ ] the police
okay hier was kann ich denn jetzt hier
was auch sonst aber das einzige was ich
eigentlich finden muss es bitte siege
wir konzentrieren uns jetzt ich bin
gerade irgendwie hierdurch in das
hallo was ist denn das hier drin rektors
kate ich wollte euch eigentlich etwas
anderes zeigen mann soll nämlich wohl
ran normal
ich krieg hat alle auszeichnungen
irgendwie eigentlich wollte ich euch
zeigen dass man im kopf ist ein
entwickler haus in diesem spiel kann man
irgendwas zocken und zwar irgendwie
happy bird auf seinem bildschirm oder so
aber jetzt haben einfach eine riesige
halfpipe gefunden ich weiß wann ich
inwiefern ich die halfpipe jetzt nutzen
kann um irgendwie was ist das hier und
was ist das hier vorne für ein
mysteriöses büro alter sorry ich hab mir
jetzt einfach mit dieses fahrrad von
mitgenommen versuche mit dem fahrrad
gibt wenn luca gold spielt sieht das
alles sehr langer zeit so aus ich habe
mir letztens ein fahrrad gekauft und die
auch schon relativ gut damit um
wie ist das denn da unten hin gekommen
meine ersten versuche auf dem fahrrad
das nicht super gut vom schon gott wir
müssen nur einmal
da sehen wir wieder wie toll dieses
spiel ist und jetzt wieder irgendwie
schnell rein in diesen laden da wie auch
immer so da bin ich da drin und jetzt
nehmen wir uns hier unten stand glaub
ich oder oder hier oder da vorne ist das
fahrrad und jetzt einfach drauf setzen
und einfach hier
es ist unglaublich schwer dieses fahrrad
zu fahren das glaubte mir das ist
unmöglich einfach geradeaus einfach
daraus ziehe einfach da gut gemacht
fahrrad
du schaffst es fahrrad hier in die boxen
rein
wenigstens habe ich ein paar punkte
bekommen schaut euch das an ich setze
mich auf das fahrrad und fall direkt
wieder um ich sitze drauf wo freunde ich
habe es tatsächlich geschafft das
fahrrad aus dieser anlage mit
rauszunehmen und destivo fahrern und ich
jetzt hingehen werden
auf diese rutsche hier ständig passend
hin fahrrad nein nicht so geht das ist
so verdammt fucking schwer dieses bike
einfach mal in der vernünftige ok
perfekt fahrrad der moment gekommen
daraus macht aus also ich hab mich echt
auf die gute aufnahme gefreut wie ja
natürlich wollte tier grundsätzlich was
anderes machen aber ich habe jetzt alles
klar